a reaction of this Perfection I mean
this is a complicated thing because at
the heart of it it's really we don't
know right we just don't know all we do
know are the facts is that Andrew
befriended this pedophile yes even after
he was convicted initially of pedophile
Behavior Andrew continued to see him
cooking for four days in New York
infamously and we also know he vowed to
clear his name and then never did yeah I
mean my problem is
um not that he
befriended Epsom when he didn't know he
was a pedophile but after he was
released from prison in full knowledge
of what he'd done he then goes to New
York to stay with them and it wasn't for
academic legal reasons
yeah he was on a jolly with his lots of
women
exactly and that is extremely
distasteful we also have the photograph
which
is not real one of the weirdest things
well not that we photographed well I
mean I I thought it looks like the mail
on Sunday have nailed the fact that that
photograph may be real but what about
the bathtub
one of the weirdest things I've ever
seen it takes it into it now we got it
again can we get it yeah it now reminds
me of the Duchess of our girls so these
are friends of the Maxwell's Elaine
Maxwell right who are pretending to be
Andrew and this girl who was his you
know the woman who's paid millions of
dollars to while saying he never met her
to prove that they couldn't defronics in
that bathtub this looks like proof of
the complete opposite Katie yeah it's an
extraordinary photograph and and clearly
doesn't do anything to clear Andrew's
name I mean I I think at the end of the
day he he said he was going to go to
court he'd be prepared to do that be
prepared to be investigated by the FBI
did none of that
um I think it sticks in the core for a
lot of people that the settlement was
deemed the easy way out I think Alan
made a good point though because he was
under huge pressure the queen wasn't
well she's coming towards the end of her
life the last thing that the royal
family would have needed was a big court
case like this they had enough with what
was going on with the court of the
sussexes across the pond but of course
Charles is now faced with all of this
and the eve of his
currently I mean the trouble is it's
always all about Andrew
um
you don't start even talking or thinking
about this sort of thing until after the
coronation right assuming he is innocent
then
if he was it's hypothetical what I'm
saying if he was it wouldn't really
matter whether he was trying to clear
his name or not because the point is
that Charles's plan for a streamlined
monarchy wasn't going to include Andrew
at the helm anyway he was going to be
demoted so this is just a distance
is a great chance for King Charles to
reset right the whole monarchy after 70
odd years of his mother's Reign his
glorious Reign this is the big moment
for him where he actually has a
coronation and his Queen consult
communities yes I mean he must be
sitting with his head in his hands
wishing um he had a rather more amiable
relatives no I would be saying why on
Earth would he even countenance having
now Barry and Megan there with all their
cameras making notes repeating again
more private conversations
I think there will be a bigger route if
if he doesn't they're absence
because they wouldn't make one the best
dancer that Harry and Megan is shut up
go away and nothing to do with anything
is you're missing the point the point of
a royal family is it has to be United
not United States
thank you why should it be all one way
why should these two Renegade because
they're King shovel dirt all over their
families
and this lasted me about all the loved
ones in the family it's Queen Victoria's
family is supposed to represent the
idealized British family and they've
always been conscious of that and it's
something the taxpayer conscious of to
they do not like to see a royal family
divided Charles doesn't have any choice
William wants to punch Harry's lights
out I was told the other day literally
very well but what happens what happens
if he sees him at the coronation decides
now's the moment I mean at the age of a
throne punching his brother in the head
yeah
if one of your family had done this
right one of your siblings or a child if
they'd done that what would you do we're
private individuals you keep it in the
private domain unfortunately Harry
hasn't done that I think his father and
his brother will show that they can do
better oh I think that honestly they
should cut him off bang done gone you
stay in Montecito you're not part of
this anymore you don't get the good
stuff you don't get the trinkets from
the institution that you've been
trashing and bearing this poll in
America last week showing massively
reduced popularity you've got all the
Royals but the most unpopular now Harry
and Megan in America right because they
just don't know what they're doing
they're doing and Charles is riding top
of those poles peers and I think to
extend that fight
they're on a mission to destroy the
monarchy and we in this country should
not accept it by the way it's not just
Charles's coronation it is the people's
correlation
we're paying for it but I've been of
people appreciate Charles acting with
dignity a man who's risen the brother
says so the most dignified thing they
can do is have the least dignified
members of his family not there that's
what I call preserving dignity the idea
of Meghan Markle and Harry after all
they've done sitting there beaming away
in the front row would make me puke well
they won't be in the front Pew I mean
just look back to the Queen's service of
Thanksgiving during the Jubilee they can
be there in a position
exactly all right gotta leave it there
thank you ladies I appreciate it